عشرات من هؤلاء المقاتلين السابقين في
صفوف تنظيم داعش هم من المغاربه
والسودانيين ينتظرون فتح ابواب هذا السجن
لكن الى سجن اخر حيث يتوقع ان يكملوا
حالهم هذا في بلادهم بعد اعادتهم اليها
زيارتان متزامنتان لمسؤولين سودانيين
ومغاربه الى سوريا والعراق لبحث ملف اعاده
مواطني الدولتين من سجناء داعش واطفالهم
فالخرطوم تسلمت امراتين وثلاثه اطفال من
المخيمات الخاصه بعوائل مقاتل التنظيم
شمال شرقي سوريا لكن الرباط تحتاج لمزيد
من الوقت الذي يفرضه عليها عدد وانتشار
مواطنيها بين العراق وسوريا
المغرب ارسل وفدا من القضاه والمستشارين
يراسه وزير العدل عبد اللطيف وهبي لعقد
اتفاقيه تمهد الطريق لتسليم مقاتل التنظيم
في السجون العراقيه
وفقا لبيانات حكوميه سابقه فان
1659 مغربيا غادروا البلاد للانضمام الى
حركات ارهابيه وان 250 مقاتلا يقبعون في
السجون السوريه بينهم عشره في السجون
العراقيه كذلك يوجد 400 قاصر في مخيمات
البلدين منهم
153 ولدوا في المغرب والبقيه في المناطق
التي استولى عليها التنظيم
الرباط وبعد نحو 18 عاما اعادت فتح
سفاراتها في بغداد ومعها اعيد فتح قضيه
مقاتل التنظيم الارهابي لتتصدر جدول اعمال
التنسيق الامني والقضائي بين البلدين
المغرب ومنذ عام 2015 سنت قانونا لمواجهه
ظاهره عوده المسلحين بعقوبات تتراوح بين
عشر و15 سنه من السجن حاكمت بمضمونه
العشرات وعشرات يستعدون انتظارا للنطق
بالحكم